voici le résultat du scrutin votant 573
exprimé 535 majorité 268 pour 349 contre
186 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté et la séance est
suspendue bonjour à tous et bienvenue
dans les grands débats dans ce numéro
nous allons revenir sur le projet de loi
immigration un parcours plein de
rebondissement qui commence par un coup
de théâtre nous sommes le lundi 11
décembre 2023 c'est le top départ de
l'examen en séance du texte l'hémicycle
est plein à craquer le ministre de
l'Intérieur présente son projet de
[Musique]
loi l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion après engagement de la
procédure accélérée du projet de loi
adopté par le Sénat pour contrôler
l'immigration et améliorer
l'intégration la parole est à Monsieur
géralin ministre de l'Intérieur et
desr l'immigration est une des grandes
questions de notre
temps concerne tous les continents
elle concerne tous les pays et elle
concerne tous les peuples si l'essentiel
les mouvements des femmes et des hommes
à travers le monde concerern avant tout
les pays du Sud les pays du Sud de la
planète touché par les
guerres touché par les désolations
économiques touché par l'islamisme
radical touché par les questions
climatiques nul ne peut ignorer que
l'Europe en général et la France en
particulier connaî une pression
migratoire
constante la souveraineté d'un peuple
réside aussi dans sa capacité à fixer
des règles des règles pour savoir qui il
veut
accueillir dans quelle proportion
d'immigration la société accepte de les
accueillir et dans quelles
conditions nous pouvons assurer
l'indispensable exigence
mesdames et messieurs les députés
débattre et légiférer sur l'intégration
et l'immigration c'est répondre à la
demande forte légitime et répété de nos
concitoyens tous ici nous le voyons et
quel que soit ce que pensent les
Français du sujet la maîtrise des flux
migratoires la difficulté de lutter
contre l'immigration
irrégulière l'accroissement des moyens
donnés au préfet aux agents de
préfecture aux magistrats aux forces de
l'ordre est un débat essentiel est un
débat nécessaire est un débat que
personne ne peut raisonnablement rejeter
d'un revers de la main sans que
l'Assemblée nationale ait pu en discuter
au moins quelques
instants nous rentrons ici avec la
conviction que des compromis doivent
être faits pour l'intérêt général pour
la protection des Français pour la
protection de nos frontières
pour l'intégration des étrangers pour la
lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière ce texte vous le savez
présente trois grands
axes une simplification drastique des
procédures aujourd'hui nous mettons trop
de temps à répondre si c'est oui ou si
c'est non pour les étrangers qui
arrivent sur notre sol plus de 2 ans en
moyenne quand le texte inspiré
directement du rapport du sénateur
buffet pré voit la division par trois
des recours et permettra de moins en
moins de 8 mois de répondre nous ne
sommes pas laxistes mais nous mettons
trop de temps à répondre et là où tous
les pays autour de nous ont été au
rendez-vous de la rapidité la rapidité
de l'administration la rapidité de la
justice nous devons absolument prendre
des mesures de simplification c'est
l'objet de trois titres entiers de ce
projet de
loi la lutte contre les étrangers
délinquants
comment peut-on réclamer de la fermeté
et refuser aux policiers aux gendarmes
au préfets les moyens d'expulser les
étrangers délincants comment peut-on
faire la une des journaux aller sur les
plateaux de télévision tenir des
meetings quand le gouvernement et la
majorité arrive avec des dispositions
pour les lui refuser et finalement
désarmer les policiers et les
gendarmes comment peut-on sciamment
s'opposer à des dispositions qui vont
nous permettre d'expulser ou d'éloigner
4000 étrangers délinquants
que ni la Constitution ni la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme ni
l'Europe nous empêche de le faire c'est
la loi de la République qui le permet
c'est la loi de la République qu'il faut
changer enfin
l'intégration il n'y a pas de politique
d'immigration qui vaille sans une
intégration forte exigeante et beaucoup
d'autres n ont connu des parents des
grandsparents parfois des députés
eux-mêmes issus de cette immigration qui
attend si fort de l'intégration
de la langue de la République du travail
du bien logement et finalement de
l'acceptation d'une société nous ne
sommes pas assez ferm nous ne donnons
pas assez de moyens ce texte de loi
répond à la grande exigence de
l'intégration lorsqu'on lit le texte
immigration disponible par chacune et
par chacun sur le site de l'Assemblée
nationale on peut se demander comment
peut-on s'opposer à la réussite
obligatoire d'un examen de français pour
avoir un titre de séjour long en France
400000 étrangers
concernés comment peut-on être opposé
opposer au cours gratuits à ces mêms
étrangers pour permettre l'intégration
et pendant leurs heures de travail
comment peut-on s'opposer aux moyens et
pouvoirs considérables donn à nos forces
de l'ordre à nos préfets à nos
magistrats comment peut-on s'opposer à
l'inspection des véhicules aux
frontières demandés par les policiers
par les gendarmes depuis plus de 40 ans
comment peut-on s'opposer à la prise
d'empreinte obligatoire pour reconnaître
l'identité des personnes et savoir
vraiment qui est majeur et qui est
mineur et de quelle nationalité il est
comment peut-on s'opposer à la
simplification drastique de notre droit
voter mesdames et messieurs les députés
à l'unanimité des sénateurs du rapport
François Noël buffet et qui divise par
trois les recours et ainsi permettra
d'améliorer évidemment les reconduites à
la frontière comment peut-on s'opposer
au retire au retrait des titres de
séjour pour tous ceux qui adhèrent à
l'islamisme radical et qui ne respectent
pas les valeurs de la République comment
peut-on s'opposer à ne plus mettre des
enfants de 3 ans ou de 5 ans dans des
centres de rétention administratifs afin
qu'ils puissent se construire
psychologiquement en dehors des
traumatismes d'aujourd'hui comment
peut-on s'opposer à la dureté demandée
par le gouvernement contre les passeurs
ces marchands de mort responsable des
noyades en Méditerranée et en Manche
aujourd'hui condamné d'un simple délit
alors que demain et je remercie le garde
des sauts ils seront passibles d'une
peine de 20 ans de prison en passant de
délit en crime que non peut-on refuser
les marchands de sommeil et leur macabre
commerce ceux qui logent dans des
conditions indignes et insalubres et
comme vous j'ai été maire avoir vu des
enfants des handicapés des vieillards
des personnes vulnérables qui sont
exploités par des personnes sans
scrupulle et qui sont responsabl de
l'immigration irrégulière comment
peut-on refuser pour la première fois la
prise en compte de la dans la
coopération migratoire de notre
politique de visa et laisser passer
consulaire comment peut-on refuser les
dispositions qui permettront plus à la
justice et notamment au juges des
libertés de la détention de libérer un
étranger dangereux d'un cras pour simple
nullité de procédure d'un policier
comment peut-on ne pas vouloir protéger
les Français et leur sécurité en
permettant l'éloignement et l'expulsion
des étrangers délinquants qui ne peuvent
pas être expulsés du territoire national
par simple loi de la République comment
peut-on raisonnablement ne pas vouloir
en débattre comment peut-on refuser ses
armes au policiers nos gendarmes comment
peut-on s'en faire la politique du pire
refuser cette
discussion bien sûr ce texte mérite
d'être amélioré et la main du
gouvernement étendu dans l'intérêt
général de tous les Français laissons
lacrimonie de côté et montrons-nous
capable comme toutes les grandes
démocraties qui se respectent de
débattre d'afficher des désaccords et de
trouver une entente commune en
respectant les oppositions pour faire de
la France la plus beau pays du monde
celui qui fait face au grand défi de
notre temps en s'écoutant et surtout en
ayant trouvé l'un et l'autre le sens des
responsabilités mesdames et messieurs
les
députés mesdames et messieurs le
gouvernement est prêt prêt à débattre
prêt à amender prêt à discuter prêt à la
fermeté et prêt à l'écoute il a pris ses
responsabilités j'imagine bien ici que
chacun prendra les
siennes premier obstacle pour le
ministre une motion de rejet préalable a
été déposée par les écologistes si elle
est adopté c'est l'arrêt pure et simple
des
débats je veux le dire en préambule aux
collègues de LR de Lyot mais aussi à
ceux qui dans la majorité doutent voter
le rejet dans un instant n'étant rien
une adhésion à mon propos et ne sera pas
instrumentalisé comme telle nos règles
parlementaires et démocratiques sont
claires je sais qu'il n'existe pas sur
ce sujet de majorité pouvant se
rattacher ici à l'analyse que je
formulerai dans un instant et je n'aurai
pas l'outre cuidance de croire que je
puisse en quelques instants vous
convaincre mais il n'existe pas
d'avantage de majorité autour du texte
du
Gouvernement et c'est bien là le seul
objet de cette motion oui ou non le
gouvernement peut-il obtenir Infiné les
voix nécessaires à l'adoption de son
projet chacune et chacun ici connaît la
réponse ce vote doit permettre d'en
apporter la
démonstration monsieur le ministre vous
n'avez pas su trouver ici les équilibres
et les compromis qui vous étaient
nécessaires par conséquent la discussion
parlementaire qui s'ouvrirait si
d'aventure nous rejetions cette motion
ne serait qu'un vaste marchandage visant
à débaucher individuellement les
nombreuses très nombreuses voies qui
vous
manquent on a fait des victimes qui fuit
la guerre ou la misère des coupables
bouc émissaire facile d'une France
déclassé par des décennies de
néolibéralisme fracturé par les
inégalités miné par les injustices
déserté par les services publics trop
souvent impuissante face au désordres du
monde notamment devant le péril
climatique au bout du compte ou plutôt
du décompte des voix
nous voilà avec quelques régularisation
dans quelques régions pour quelques
métiers en tension le tout dans une
période d'expérimentation qui ne
survivrait pas à la durée du quinquena
c'est mieux que rien mais c'est presque
rien par ailleurs de notre point de vue
faire des nouveaux arrivants des
variables d'ajustement économique selon
le niveau de tension de tel ou tel
métier dans tel ou tel territoire
revient à les déshumanisés à les privés
de dignité c'est une rupture grave dans
les principes du du droit du
travail on ne gouverne pas la France à
coup de formule comptable mais avec des
principes et des valeurs qui nous
obligent notre point d'équilibre à nous
n'est pas compatible avec votre texte
notre exigence va vers une politique
d'humanité qui ne peut être équidistante
d'aucune prétendue fermeté cette fameuse
fermeté parlons-en en 40 ans et 30 lois
sur l'immigration elle n'aura produit
que deux effets l'inflation des revenus
des passeurs qui indexent leurs tarifs
sur les difficultés à franchir nos
frontières et la hausse terrifiante du
nombre de morts en Méditerranée ou dans
les
Alpes la lucidité c'est comprendre que
celui qui s'est arraché à sa terre
engageant un long chemin sans retour qui
a vécu la violence la faim la peur
parfois la torture ou le viol puis a vu
ses compagnons d'infortune flotter sous
forme de cadavre en Méditerranée avant
d'être traqué par la police dans le
froid des Alpes celui-là celle-là n'est
pas connecté à la chaîne parlementaire
pour se demander si telle disposition
législative va lui octroyer ou le priver
de tel droit de telle allocation de
telle protection l'appel d'air n'existe
pas laissons laissons les familles se
réunir les gens s'aimer les malades se
soigner et que cesse le harcèlement des
humanitaires la criminalisation de la
solidarité la lucidité c'est regarder
les chiffres la part des étrangers
France est globalement stable depuis des
décennies nous accueillons moins que
nombre de nos voisins et bien moins que
la plupart des pays du Sud qui sont le
point d'arrivée de la majeure partie des
migrations non il ne nous a pas demandé
d'accueillir ou pas je ne sais quelle
juste part de la misère du monde la
lucidité c'est refuser l'enfermement des
enfants leur abandon ou la négation de
leur
[Applaudissements]
minorités la lucidité c'est sortir la
comptabilité des étudiants étrangers des
statistiques de l'immigration et
reconnaître que pour la plupart ils
repartent dans leur pays et ils font
rayonner la France qu'ils réussissent
mieux leurs études et rapportent 1,35
milliards d'euros chaque année à notre
économie soyons fiers pour notre
influence notre recherche notre modèle
universitaire d'accueillir tous ces
talents la lucidité c'est comprendre que
l'intégration ne peut se résumer à une
injonction elle est un processus de
socialisation qui implique une
progression dans le temps c'est l'action
politique qui peut créer les conditions
de cette inclusion en levant les
obstacles économiques sociaux éducatif
linguistique culturel et
civique pour diriger un pays aussi beau
et grand que la France il faut une
boussole qui donne un cap quel est le
vôtre sur ce texte vous avez dit gentil
avec les gentils méchant avec les
méchant mais Monsieur le Ministre on ne
gouverne pas la France avec des slogans
de cours d'école les Français ne sont
pas des en enfant pas plus que les
parlementaires vous avez perdu vos
repères vous avez renoncé à assumer une
conviction sans pour autant en
rencontrer d'autres ni à gauche ni à
droite de cet
hémicycle je constate que la somme des
soutiens de ce texte est inférieure à la
somme des opposants dans cette assemblée
cette réalité est la seule qui compte en
cet instant mes chers collègues rejetons
ce mauvais texte maintenant
un débat aussi important que celui-ci
sans doute parmi les controverses les
plus importantes politiquement et
moralement de notre époque mérite mieux
qu'un petit texte porté par une petite
majorité alors finalement j'en vous
entends monsieur Luc vous demandz le
rejet pas le rejet du texte le rejet du
débat l'Assemblée
nationale l'Assemblée nationale ne
pourrait pas débattre
ne pourrait pas débattre ici et
maintenant de toutes les mesures que je
vous ai grainé des 2600 amendements
proposés par les
parlementaire mais alors pourquoi passer
une semaine en commission monsieur
Lucas pourquoi ne pas évoquer tous
ensemble l'absence de votre groupe
politique et ceux de l'opposition pour
rejeter ce qu'a très bien dit le
président de la commission des lois en
commission peut-être parce que les
médias n'étaient pas aussi présents et
j'ai peur que votre opposition ne soit
méiatique
je n'ai pas peur du débat parce que vous
savez il y a des millions de Français
qui regardent les débats que nous
avons des millions et des millions qui
vont voir les députés du rassemblement
national et certains députés des
républicains voter avec Monsieur Lucas
qui veut la régularisation de T les S
papier les Français doivent comprendre
qu'une partie de la droite va voter à
canupes qui décide désormais hors du
champ
républicain et qu'il refuse et qu'il
refuse et qu'il refuse la main tendue du
gouvernement s'il vous
plaît mesdames et messieurs les
députés nous vous proposons de
débre nous proposons de qui est digne en
politique c'està-dire des
désaccords nous vous montrons la
possibilité de
compromis et le gouvernement arrive avec
l'idée qu'il pourrait trouver ce
compromis prouver de longues semaines de
discussion Siger l'assoir siéger la nuit
siéger le
weekend et avoir la possibilité enfin de
changer la vie des
Français avoir la possibilité d'armer
nos policiers nos gendarmes et nos
magistrats
le gouvernement et la majorité est clair
nous sommes ouverts au débats nous
sommes ouverts au compromis nous sommes
ouverts à la discussion mais il est vrai
que pour discuter pour faire avancer les
Français il faut être au moins
de je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre mais alors vont faire les
différents groupes politiques le
rassemblement national en entrant dans
l'hémicycle a gardé secrète sa consigne
de vote mais ici dans cette salle des
quatre colonnes la rumeur enfle le
rassemblement national pourrait voter en
faveur de la motion de rejet ce que nous
confirme à demi-mot un député cette
motion de rejet encore une fois est un
outil à la disposition de l'Assemblée
national pour rejeter un texte qui
encore une fois ne remplit pas son son
objectif VO la droite elle se réunit
dans un bureau à côté de l'hémicycle
erriic sootti le président du parti
Olivier marlex le président du groupe
pousse pour que les députés les
républicains votent la motion de rejet
il retourne dans l'hémicycle et les
explications de vote
commence mes chers
collègues cette motion rime avec
irresponsabilité
irresponsabilité car son adoption
priverait la représent représentation
nationale d'un débat qui quel qu'en soit
l'issue est indispensable et souhaité
par les Français irresponsabilité car
son adoption priverait l'état de
nouveaux moyens pour choisir qui est en
droit de séjourner sur notre territoire
et à quelles conditions
irresponsabilité car son adoption
priverait la justice de la possibilité
de prendre toutes les mesures utiles à
la préservation de l'ordre public
irresponsabilité car son adoption
priverit notre diplomatie de nouveau Mo
y pour contraindre les étap pe
coopératifs à délivrer les laisser
passer consulair ses âmes indispensables
à les exécutions réelles des TF il en va
de la responsabilité de chaque groupe de
cette hémicycle pour que ce débat ait
lieu le groupe Horizon est apparenté
vottera contre cette motion de rejet
préalable car l'inverse reviendrait à et
la raison d'être de notre mandat
débattre nous ne voulons pas d'uneè loi
sur l'immigration qui s'inscrive dans
une logique répressive et
sécuritaire nous ne voulons pas qu'à
l'image des débats au Sénat et en
commission des lois l'Assemblée
nationale puisse être la caisse de
résonance de propos abjects aineux
xénophobe essentialisant à l'encontre
des
étrangers nous ne voulons pas d'une loi
qui attaque notre cohésion sociale en
pointant l'étranger comme suspect comme
fraudeur comme
délinquant la menace dans notre pays ce
n'est pas l'étranger ce sont les mots de
l'extrême droite nous ne voulons pas
d'une loi pour mener monsieur le
ministre une course électorale avec
l'extrême droite en réalité vous ne
menez pas la course et vous le savez ce
que vous faites c'est que vous validez
leur thèse et que vous leur donnez le
point le groupe tient à ce que notre
assemblée examine et débat du projet de
loi immigration et intégration parce que
le pays le demande notre pays qui
oublieent européenne subit une crise
migratoire hors norme chaque jour
environ 100 migrants arrivent
illégalement à maotte un habitant sur
deux est étranger à Mayotte la plupart
en situation irrégulière le trafic
humain l'économie illégale le vol des
terres des biens les violences
quotidiennes font basculer maottes dans
l'anarchie nous maorè sommes dépossédés
des services publics monopolisés par les
étrangers toujours plus nombreux
toujours en grande détresse la réalité
des grands principes de certains c'est
que l'accueil des étrangers n'a pas de
prix mais il a un coût et maotte le paye
cher l'état refuse tout avancé sur le
développement de nos infrastructures de
nos droits sociaux au motif de l'appel
d'air on interdit à vos compatriotes de
maotte de sortir de l'inégalité en droit
parce que les étrangers peuvent y
accéder en masse sur notre territoire
face à cette tragédie et aux limites de
la dépense publique il faut faire des
choix parce qu'aucun système ne peut
tenir sans la contribution et la de tous
notre souveraineté est attaquée à
Mayotte notre île est menacée
déstabilisée par l'affux migratoire
l'Assemblée doit regarder l'immigration
en face et débattre alors aujourd'hui un
certain nombre d'entre vous chers
collègues vous nous proposez de rejeter
ce texte au préalable sans même
l'étudier alors que ce sujet fait partie
des sujets alors que ça fait partie des
sujets de préoccupation principaux des
Français vous nous proposez sérieusement
cet après-midi de purement et simplement
l'éluder alors que la raison d'être de
notre notre institution parlementaire
c'est de permettre la confrontation des
idées politiques vous souhaitez empêcher
le débat de ce qui représente un des
plus grands défi de notre
siècle chers collègues si vous votez
cette motion de rejet ça signifie que
vous rejetez toutes les mesures qui
permettront demain une meilleure
intégration par le travail et par la
langue si vous rejetez ce texte les
Français sauront que vous refusez de
discuter des mesures qui visent à lutter
contre l'immigration clandestine
particulièrement en criminalisant les
passeurs et en luttant contre les mar
champ de sommeil si vous votez cette
motion nous ne pourrons pas inscrire
dans la loi l'interdiction dans les des
mineurs dans les cras avec cette motion
vous expliquerez aussi aux français
qu'on ne se donne pas les moyens
d'expulser les étrangers délinquants
dangereux pour la société française
chers collègues entendez les Français
qui sont équeœurés par les jeux
politiciens soyez à nos côtés pour
redorer le blason de notre assemblée en
bâtissant un texte utile et efficace
soyez responsable et écarter cette
motion de Roget merci monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur depuis plusieurs
jours vous courez les plateaux télé vous
enchaînez les tweet les mails et vous
osez venir à la tribune de l'Assemblée
nationale pour nous dire honte à ceux
qui ne veulent pas débattre monsieur le
ministre vos provocations au-delà de
faire éclater au grand jour les
divergences qui fracturent votre
majorité et votre fébrilité sont
indécentes elles sont indécentes parce
que quand on appartient à un
gouvernement à ce point adepte des 493
on ne vient pas donner des leçons de
démocratie
elles sont indécentes car quand on a
votre bilan 120 attaqu au couteau par
jour un taux d'exécution des des octf
qui n'atteint même pas les 7 % des
subventions aux associations
immigrationnistes qui frôent le milliard
d'euros entre 600000 et 900000
clandestins qui vivent sur notre sol et
plus de 400000 étrangers légaux qui
entrent en France chaque année on ne
vient pas donner des leçons en matière
de protection des Français vous
présentez aujourd'hui une nouvelle loi
pour contrôler l'immigration monsieur le
ministre la 117e depuis 1945 la 30e
depuis 1980 la 4e sous le règne de la
macronie en 8 ans 1700 km de frontières
supplémentaires ont été dressés dans
l'Union européenne pour quel résultat
monsieur le ministre une Haus des prix
sur le marché des passages et des mers
transformé en tombeau de l'humanité vos
politiques migratoires c'est des morts
en
Méditerranée enfin monsieur le ministre
se préoccuper des questions migratoires
c'est s'attaquer aux causes réelles des
migrations les interventions
impérialistes le capitalisme l'inaction
climatique qui force des millions de
personnes à l'exil c'est pourquoi nous
voterons en faveur de C mon votre texte
et quitte le
ministère monsieur le ministre depuis 18
mois personne ne peut contester que les
députés les républicains aucun de vos
collègues ne peut contester que nous
sommes allés dans le sens de l'intérêt
général en votant les textes à chaque
fois qu'il nous paraissait nécessaire et
utile au pays les Français attendent un
changement attendent un changement
radical mais le texte sorti de la
commission des lois est une fausse
promesse pire monsieur le ministre pire
ce texte permettra un droit à la
régularisation et entraînera des
régularisations massives ça nous ne
pouvons pas l'accepter dans l'intérêt de
notre pays alors oui monsieur le
ministre le débat doit se poursuivre il
doit se poursuivre mais sur la base du
texte de fermeté proposé par le Sénat
c'est le sens de la motion de rejet que
nous soutiendrons en commission nous
avons travailler longuement et vous avez
reconnu l'intérêt de ce travail donc
j'avoue aujourd'hui ne pas comprendre
pourquoi tout d'un coup au milieu du gay
vous décidez d'arrêter de travailler
déciderz tout simplement de faire ce qui
fait notre crédibilité et notre
responsabilité travailler au service des
Français messieurs et mesdames à ma
gauche à la droite de cet hémicycle j'ai
du mal à vous comprendre également
depuis des mois et des mois vous ne
parlez que
d'immigration depuis des mois et des
mois vous ne faites de ce sujet que le
point sur le qu'il faut que vous
traitiez c'est votre seul
aujourd'hui nous nous retrouvons pour
travailler et puis devant l'obstacle
vous fuyez devant l'obstacle vous
arrêter le combat j'avoue je ne
comprends pas c'est pas très digne et
franchement les Français ne le
comprendront pas messieurs et Madam les
républicain monsieur marlex je vous ai
entendu je vous rappelle que pendant la
Commission on a eu un gros travail un
travail où vous étiez invité on vous y a
pas
vu et pour débat démocratique évid
groupemoc votera contre cette motion de
rejet à l'évidence ce texte ne contente
pas grand monde il mécontente ceux qui
ont reçu des gages au Sénat et je peux
comprendre que le président du groupe LR
qui voulait durcir le texte à
l'Assemblée se sente totalement floué
après le passage en commission il
mécontente surtout ceux à qui monsieur
le ministre vous aviez promis un texte
d'intégration alors que en réalité c'est
un éème texte de posture dont on peut
déjà vous prédire l'inefficacité on
accueillera pas mieux on nintégrera pas
mieux on ne reconduira pas mieux on
naméliorera pas la jungle procédurale du
droit des étrangers depuis des mois vous
tirez des bords entre les attentes
divergentes de la macronie les les
exigences folles de la droite et les
incantation de l'extrême droite quand un
ministre a perdu sa boussole
républicaine la seule urgence c'est
d'arrêter sa course
folle comprenez que les lois et les
décret des bouts de papier insignifiants
quand on est guidé par un instinct de
survie croire en la dissuasion
migratoire relève du même myth que
croire en l'appel d'air ce texte n'est
qu'un mensonge aux français auquel on
tente de faire croire que le code pénal
pourrait être l'alpha et l'oméga d'une
politique migratoire votre crédau
exclusif c'est contrôler dissuader punir
vous voulez de l'ordre vous aurez
confusion et pagaille vous voulez de
l'efficacité vous aurez le bourbier des
contentieux vous voulez de la sécurité
vous n'aurez que des peurs qui sont
sources de toutes les insécurités parce
que ce texte est porteur de désordre
plus grand que ce que vous prétendez
combattre nous voterons pour cette
motion de
rejet le moment du vote arrive dans
l'hémicycle les ministres et les députés
retiennent leur souffle et ici les
journalistes
aussi le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos voici le résultat du scrutin votant
548 exprimé 535 majorité 268 pour 270
contre
265 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté en conséquence le projet de loi
est
rejeté c'est le scénario catastrophe
pour le gouvernement l'examen du texte
s'arrête salle des quatre colonnes
la droite et le rassemblement national
vient crier
victoire c'est la sanction de la
duplicité du ministre de
l'Intérieur ministre de la droite la
plus dure au
Sénat ministre de la compromission à
l'Assemblée
nationale c'est au fond l'épuisement du
en même temps c'est un rendez-vous
manqué sur une question importante pour
les Françaises et les Français mais sa
force de vouloir contenter prétendument
tout le monde on mécontente
l'intégralité des bands de cette
assemblée dire simplement l'émotion qui
est la notre et notre fierté d'avoir
empêché un mauvais texte pour nos
libertés un mauvais texte pour la
conception que nous nous faisons de la
République et de la fraternité
l'inspiration de ce texte c'est
clairement les thèmes et les termes que
l'extrême droite a mis à l'un poison
dans le débat public depuis 30 ou 40 ans
nous savons évidemment que nous ne
sommes pas encore
au bout du chemin ni législatif ni
politique et moral sur ce sujet mais
c'est un point d'appui pour la bataille
que nous menons pour les valeurs auxquel
nous croyons et je me réjouis que
l'Assemblée nationale a pris acte de
l'impace dans laquelle la macronie s'est
trouvé que le groupe parlementaire de la
France enoumise est extrêmement heureux
que cette motion de rejet a été votée
par l'Assemblée nationale et donc est
rejeté le texte dès le début de l'examen
à l'Assemblée nationale parce que
d'abord nous allons épargner au pays de
semaines de discours xénophobe et
raciste et je crois que ça va aider à
mieux respirer dans ce pays que de ne
pas avoir ces débats qui se tiendront à
l'Assemblée nationale nous avions déposé
une motion de
rejet nous l'avons en toute cohérence
aujourd'hui adopté non pas pour
interrompre les débats sur un sujet
essentiel mais pour que les débats se
poursuivent sur une base beaucoup plus
crédible que celle qui avait été
empruntée par la majorité en détricotant
totalement le texte du Sénat nous
voulons débattre et adopter dans son
intégralité sans ajout sans modification
le texte du Sénat que contrairement à ce
que Monsieur Darmanin a voulu dire les
derniers jours cette loi était une loi
pro immigration qui envisageait
d'organiser l'accueil de plus en plus
d'immigrés il n'en était pas question
nous ne pouvons donc que nous réjouir de
cela quant à se faire donner des leçons
de débat par un gouvernement qui en est
je crois à son 20e
493 il faut quand même un poil manquer
de
dessence le gouvernement décide de
convoquer une CMP une commission mixte
paritaire c'est la réunion entre se
députés et se sénateur chargés de
trouver un compromis Après d'apres
négociation cette CMP et conclusive
c'est Marine Le Pen qui va réagir en
premier salalele des quatre colonnes et
là encore elle va créer la surprise on a
assisté avec cette CMP et grâce au vote
de la motion de rejet à laquelle nous
avons participé un
durcissement de la loi de Monsieur
Darmanin qui n'est pas évidemment
suffisante c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire il y a encore beaucoup à faire mais
sous la pression je crois de l'électorat
du rassemblement national cette loi
devient une loi de durcissement des
conditions de l'immigration nous allons
donc voter euh cette ce texte tel qu'il
ressort de la commission mixte
paritaire un texte durci par la droite
soutenu par l'extrême droite et la
majorité est plongée dans un profond
malaise il est 21h30 les les conclusions
de la commission mixte paritaire sont
présentées dans l'hémicycle avant un
ultime
vote ce texte nous aura appris une chose
il n'y a pas d'opposition constructive
en France il n'y a que des opposants qui
se détestent entre eux qui s'agisse de
laanupè
ou qu'il s'agit du rassemblement
national vous avez fu débat vous avez
refusé d'accomplir votre fonction de
parlementaire qui de
débattre
et vous saviez que par une petite
manœuvre
politicienne vous ne rejetiez pas le
texte proposé par le gouvernement
d'ailleurs vous n'en proposiez aucun
autre
alternatif vous rejetiez le débat et
envoyez le texte élaboré au Sénat
directement au commission mixte
paritaire on se paye pas de mot ni de
trct le discours sur les plateaux de
télévision concrètement on change la vie
ici on régularise et il y aura plus
d'enfants dans les centres de rétention
Bouchez vos oreilles mais ce texte est
le texte qui permet de régler ces
problèmes ce texte mesdames messieurs
les députés proposé par le gouvernement
voilà plus d'un an connaissez 27
articles à la fin de la commission mixte
paritaire 26 de ces articles ont été
validés alors aujourd'hui dans ce texte
ce qui certes n'est pas parfait mais qui
permet de prendre nos
responsabilités il y a c'est vrai des
avancées considérabl et des difficultés
à laquelle la majorité va apporter un
certain nombre je l'espère de soutiens
qui nous per permettront de montrer aux
Français que nous prenons nos
responsabilités et que la politique est
toujours un art difficile quand on
l'exerce avec des responsabilités
oui aujourd'hui nous allons simplifier
le droit des étrangers 12 procédures
pour permettre aujourd'hui le
contentieux 3 demain imaginez que nous
divisons par 4 ces procédure nous irons
plus vite nous pourrons très vite dire
oui ou très vite dire non mais nous le
devons à tous les étrangers qui croi en
la France que ceux qui respectent la
République soit accepté que ceux qui ne
la respectent pas soi reconduit
oui nous allons mettre
fin à l'action
insupportable supportable des passeurs
des trafiquants qui utilisent des femmes
et des enfants qui viennent mourir en
Méditerranée comme dans la Manche et que
vous soutenez manifestement ne votant
pas les dispositifs puisque nous
considérons que c pas un délit mais un
crime c'est pas 5 an mais 20 ans de
prison et quand on veut des mesures
fortes on doit voter ce texte contre des
marchands de mort qui prend l'argent
liquide pour permettre à des enfants de
monter sur des canaux de sauvetage en
leur promettant la lune qu' ne trouvent
d'ailleurs pas oui
dans ce texte il y a des avancées
considérables pour lutter contre les
marchands de sommeil tous ces logeurs
tous ceux qui ont été Mair ici savent
qu'il y a des enfants des femmes des
vieillards des handicapés qui vivent
dans des logements privés
insalubres que personne ne vérifie et
demain la pénalisation est au
rendez-vous de ces marchands de sommeil
enfin un délit enfin une condamnation et
enfin nous donneront comme pour ceux qui
subissent la prostitution un titre de
séjour pour ceux qui dénoncent ce qui
les dans des conditions contraires à la
dignité humaine
oui dans ce texte il y a l'examen de
français quand on veut avoir un titre de
plusieurs années sur le sol national et
c'est normal d'avoir un examen de
français et des cours gratuit en échange
et pour la première fois pour la
première fois nous obligerons les
employeurs à créer une forme de 1 %
intégration c'est pendant les heures de
travail qu'on prendra ses cours de
français c'est pas quand la dame aura
fait 1 he et de de R pour nettoyer vos
bureaux 1 he de pour repartir qu'on leur
dira faut aller à la préfecture à
14h il y a dans ce texte fait qu'on
protège au forces de l'ordre qu'on va
permettre à nos policiers à nos
gendarmes d'avoir les mêmes moyens que
les douaniers aux frontières qui va nous
permettre aujourd'hui à nos policiers à
nos gendarmes de regarder ce qui se
passe dans des véhicules quand ils
contrôlent ses frontières qui vont nous
permettre de décliner les normes avancé
européenne que le rassemblement national
refuse d'ailleurs l'asile à la frontière
l'enregistrement des étrangers à
frontière et aujourd'hui au niveau
européen comme au niveau français le
Rassemblement National veut des
problèmes et pas de solution parce que
ce qu'il veut mesdames et messieurs les
députés c'est plus de problème pour plus
de voix alors que no solutions que nous
apportons nous répondons au français à
leurs contraintes à leurulté et à leur
demande ce texte n'est pas
parfait ce texte est
cependant dans la responsabilité que
doivent avoir les femmes et les hommes
de bonne volonté qui répondent à l'appel
du peuple
il est la conséquence de la majorité
relative et je veux le dire ici les
débats ont été longs les insultes ont
été nombreuses les anathèmes ont été
extrêmement innombrables mais nous
n'avons jamais utilisé le 493 nous avons
toujours été ouvert au débat et c'est
vous qui l'avez
refusé il faut agir et ce projet de loi
est une pierre indispensable à l'édifice
de cette réconciliation parce qu'il
donne les moyens à l'administration et à
la justice de faire les choix naire à la
préservation de notre cohésion sociale
ce texte est indispensable aussi car il
replace les valeurs de la République
ainsi que la langue et le travail au
cœur de l'intégration cette exigence
républicaine ce n'est pas même une
condition c'est un préalable
l'immigration ne saurait conduire à un
délitement de nos valeurs non elle ne
saurait conduire à s'éloigner de l'idée
que nousous faisons de la France du
respect de la défense de nos valeurs
fondamentales celles qui structurent
notre pays les valeurs de la République
retrouver un état puissant c'est aussi
assumé de dire que ce texte est
insuffisant car pour reprendre le
contrôle et maîtriser l'immigration nous
avons besoin de l'Union européenne la
France n'est pas une île et même quand
on est une île comme la Grande-Bretagne
cela n'est pas si facile mais faire
croire qu'une politique isolée et
individuelle de la France au sein d'un
espace de libre circulation des
personnes est possible c'est un mensonge
pur et simple tâchons d'être à la
hauteur et de ne pas jouer avec les
fractures de notre pays il en va de
notre responsabilité individuelle et
collective le groupe Horizon est
apparent et votera ce texte car nous
sommes responsables et conscients de nos
devoirs de députés qui sommes là pour
faire la loi de représentant de nos
électeurs qui nous demandent un texte et
à l'égard de la France que nous devons
armer pour faire face au défi de notre
temps un texte qui traite des étrangers
votter avec l'extrême droite par
l'extrême droite et pour l'extrême
droite jamais je n'aurais cru que ce
soit possible dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale vous avez cédé
et vous avez surtout
cédé restreignant le regroupement
familial faisant revenir la préférence
nationale pour les prestations sociales
dans le droit
français mett en fin à l'automaticité du
droit du
sol faisant la déchéance de nationalité
facilitant les expulsions et les mesures
d'éloignement restaurant le délit de
séjour irrégulier pour la première fois
de l'histoire de la 5è rép vous avez
touché au droit du sol c'est un crime
indélébile sur notre devise républicaine
des voix se sont élevés jusqu'au sein du
gouvernement pour que ce texte ne soit
pas soumis au vote ce soir il est encore
temps collègues d'arrêter cette farce
grotesque qui vire au drame il est temps
collègues de nous souvenir des raisons
pour lesquelles nous sommes ici de
l'histoire dont nous sommes les
dépositaires et des valeurs qui nous
appartientent de défendre nous devons
empêcher aujourd'hui l'effondrement de
la République et au final de la
démocratie l'engloutissement sous les
thèmes et les termes mis dans le débat
public tel un poison par la famille Le
Pen collègue
réveillons-nous l'histoire nous regarde
chers collègues n'ajoutez pas le
déshonneur à la compromission rejetez ce
texte de la honte
oui la honte la honte pour un président
de la République élu pour faire barrage
à l'extrême droite la honte pour notre
pays et ses valeurs dev voir ici un
texte qui s'apparente à un trac du Front
national avec les mots de Jean-Marie Le
Pen dans le texte certains articles
reprennent les mêmes formules et les
mêmes propositions défendues depuis des
décennies par le Front national
préférence nationale quota caution de
retour pour les étudiants étrangers
atteinte au droit du sol déchéance de
nationalité à celles et ceux qui
s'étranglent devant cette rédition ne
sauvez pas que votre honneur refusez
laabîme nos désaccords nombreux
persisteront
mais cette dernière digue ce dernier
rempart face à une idéologie mortifère
qui fait de l'étranger la 5è colonne
devrait nous conduire au même vote les
dispositions ajoutées en CMP vont
renforcer la misère et la précarité
parce que vous n'avez pas de réponse
politique à proposé au désordre du monde
à commencé par la crise sociale que nous
traversons c'est la politique du bouc
émissaire l'étranger et le pauvre comme
etdemi il existe des droits inaliénables
lorsqu'on accepte de les daigner à
certains alors ils sont fragilisés pour
tous cette folie raciste vous conduit
même à couper les allocations familial
ou la prime de rentrée scolaire à des
enfants français au prétexte qu'ils ont
des des parents étrangers tout cela est
une folie refusez-la mes chers collègues
je vous le dis solennellement vous allez
écrire ce soir une page de notre
histoire l'histoire d'un pays qui en ce
19 décembre pourrait renoncer à ses
valeurs ses valeurs humanistes et bascul
le pire ne faites pas ça nous souhaitons
de l'équilibre nous souhaitons protéger
nos compatriotes mais en même temps nous
souhaitons intégrer les étrangers en
situation irrégulière qui travaillent et
qui crée de la
valeur lorsque l'on est en situation
irrégulière qu'on ne respecte pas le
droit
républicain lorsqu'on ne respecte pas
l'ordre public on n pas sa place sur le
territoire français mais lorsqu'on
travaille en France qu'on crée de la
valeur qu'on paye des impôts on a le
droit à un statut lorsque l'on veut
vivre dans un pays il est important d'en
connaître la langue pour en faciliter
l'intégration mais lorsqu'une entreprise
veut employer un étranger en situation
irrégulière il est normal qu'elle
participe au financement de son
apprentissage pour encore une fois
apprendre la langue et s'intégrer
lorsqu'un étranger entre et entrer en
état de manière irrégulière sur les
territoires l'ancien article 621 du cza
il est important pour nous de le
rétablir car c'est une demande de nos
forces de police de nos forces de
sécurité pour un meilleur suivi des
étrangers présents sur notre territoire
mais lorsqu'un employeur exploite un
étranger en situation irrégulière il est
légitime qu'il soit sanctionné notre
groupe fort de ses horizons divers et
reste partagé sur ce texte certains
d'entre vous en effet d'entre nous ont
décidé d'apporter sa voix à ce texte
quand d'autres ont décidé plutôt de s'y
opposer ou de s'y abstenir sur ce texte
mon groupe a d'emblé désigné
collectivement ces lignes rouges et je
constate que celles-ci ont été
respecté premièrement sur la création
d'un dispositif de régularisation pour
les travailleurs étrangers dans le
secteur en tension il est heureux que la
justesse de telle dispositions ait été
reconnue je le redis ici comme je l'ai
toujours fait nos entreprises nos serv
publics ont besoin de travailleurs
étrangers prêts à s'y
engager l'interdiction de tout mineur
dans les centres de rétention
administrative était également un point
sur lequel nous n'avons jamais voulu
transiger de même l'éborgement d'urgence
est un droit qui ne saurait être remise
en cause sans aller à l'encontre de la
tradition d'accueil et la solidarité de
la France il continuera à s'appliquer
envers tous ceux qui sont dans le
besoin bien entendu on ne sort jamais
d'un négociation pleinement satisfait et
je regrette que le texte final comporte
encore un trop grand nombre de
dispositions susceptibles d'être censuré
par le juge constitutionnel elles ne
sont pas de notre fait aujourd'hui
lorsque je regarde notre
hémicycle qui sont les seuls
responsables qui sont les seuls qui
étaient prêt à débattre et voter un
texte équilibré nous et donc en accord
avec la responsabilité qui s'impose à
tout parti qui se dit de gouvernement
nous voterons ce projet de loi vous avez
un bilan en matière d'immigration un
triste bilan 1,6 million de titres de
séjour délivrés à des immigrés
extrauropéen rien qu'en 2022 entre 700
et 900000 étrangers clandestins sur le
territoire national 400000 bénéficiaires
de laame en 2022 pour un coût d'un
milliard d'euros des demandes d'asile
triplé en 10 ans des TF très peu
exécutés vous êtes d'ailleurs sans doute
l'un des plus mauvais ministres en la
matière chers
collègues je le crois sincèrement nos
idées sont
initialement insuffisant et même
immigrationniste ce projet de loi a
considérablement évolué avec le soutien
des Français nous avons fait plier le
gouvernement si ce texte est loin d'être
parfait nous avons
imposé nous avons imposé des avancé
majeur autant de mesures que nous
portons depuis des années et qui sont L
plébisité par les Français et qui se
retrouve ce soir dans ce texte de loi
cette victoire idéologique cette
reconnaissance de nos solutions prouve
s'il le fallait que la politique que
vous avez mené jusqu'à présent celle du
en même temps ne fonctionne pas le texte
c'est l'annonce d'une catastrophe
sociale et sanitaire la promotion du
racisme et du rejet de l'autre
l'roduction préférence nationale
l'inscription dans la loi du programme
de Jean-Marie Le
Pen ce projet de loi est un échec
comment osez-vous dire que nous avons
voté avec le rassemblement national vous
qui en reprenez l'idéologie et le
programme comment osez-vous dire que le
durcissement du texte et de notre
responsabilité alors que dès le départ
vous le saviez destiné à une commission
mixte paritaire dominée par la droite
extrême vous les députés aujourd'hui le
programme sur lequel vous avez été élu
est mort et enterré choisissez-vous de
faire des plus vulnérables de nouveaux
pauvres choisissez-vous de vous aligner
sur les conditions posées par le Front
national il n'y a pas de mandat
impératif en République comme
parlementaire nous sommes libres et ce
soir vous avez un choix la collaboration
ou la République défaudons nos
traditions républicaines sans compromis
ni compromission liberté égalité
fraternité le texte c'est le fascisme en
marche vive la République vive la France
retirez votre
texte trois mesures importantes sur la
nationalité exprime cette idée simple
que la France comme toutes les nations
doit apprendre à se faire respecter à
faire respecter son autorité la
déchéance de nationalité pour les
binationaux coupables d'omicide sur un
policier ou un
gendarme la fin du droit du sol
automatique à la majorité pour les
enfants nés en France de parents
étrangers ils devront en manifester la
volonté entre leurs 16 ans et leurs 18
ans parce qu'on devient pas français par
hasard on ne devient pas français sans
le vouloir
et
enfin la restriction du droit du sol
pour en exclure les délinquants condamné
à une peine de 10 ans de
prison ce texte marque un véritable
tournant pour la première fois depuis
longtemps la France se donne les moyens
de reprendre le contrôle de sa politique
migratoire il est animé par un principe
simple moins d'immigration et plus
d'expulsion des étrangers indésirable
pour le groupe modem l'identité de la
France c'est l'image d'une terre
d'accueil par son histoire sa place dans
le monde c'est celle du rayonnement de
son savoir de sa culture de sa langue et
les Français que veulent-ils au groupe
démocrat nous sommes convaincus qu'ils
attendent de nous de la fermeté du bon
sens et de l'humanité ils attendent que
les règles soient respectées quand une
ooctf est délivrée elle doit être mise
en œuvre dans les meilleurs délais quand
un étranger arrive il doit apprendre
notre langue et quand un émigré
travaille paye des impôts des
cotisations sociales alors il doit il a
le droit d'avoir une carte de séjour
parce que nous avons besoin de lui et
s'il travaille et bien il doit aussi
toucher des prestations qui sont la base
de notre contrat social à l'égal de tous
les autres cotisants ce texte n'est pas
parfait nous le savons mais il est le
fruit de compromis démocratique que nous
voulons assumer pleinement par au groupe
démocrate nous respectons chacun parce
que les deux mots qui nous guident
depuis toujours conscience et
responsabilité les députés du groupe
démocrate que j'ai l'honneur de présider
sont libres de leur vote je vous remerci
où en
sommes-nous la question n'est pas
seulement de savoir avec qui vous allez
voter mais plus certainement ce que vous
allez voter une politique de côas
migratoire
débattu au Parlement comme le voulait
François Fillon la préférence nationale
victoire de Jean-Marie Le Pen pour
l'accès à de nombreuses prestations
sociales aussi essentielles que les
allocations familiales où en sommes-nous
ce soir un durcissement des conditions
du regroupement familial un
rétrécissement du titre étranger malade
des étudiants étrangers dissuadés de
venir par le paiement d'une caution une
atteinte au droit du sol
une régession des régularisation par le
travail le retour de la double peine de
la déchéance
dealité le rétablissement du délit de
séjour irrégulier le renforcement des
conditions de l'aide au développement la
remise en cause de l'inconditionnalité
de l'accueil la réduction des droits des
déboutés du droit d'asile et comme si ce
ne suffisait pas demain la promesse
d'une révision de
l'Ame qu'est-ce que cette loi mes chers
collègues une mauvaise loi de police des
étrangers c'est le programme du
rassemblement l'osé et les mains sales
ce texte est celui d'un gouvernement
agissant sous la dicté de la droite et
de de l'extrême droite rien ne vous
oblige à les suivre dans le déshonneur
il y a dans cet hémicycle une majorité
pour ajouter de la peur à la peur de
l'indignité à l'indignité du malheur au
malheur l'histoire vous regarde il est
temps de repousser ce texte et de voter
contre vive la république et vive la
France je vais mettre au voix le projet
de loi tel qu'il est issu de la
commission mixte paritaire je vous
demande de bien vouloir regagner vos
place le scrutin est
[Applaudissements]
ouvert le scrutin est
clos voici le résultat du scrutin votant
573 exprimé 535 majorité 268 pour 349
contre 186 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté et la séance est
suspendue le projet de loi immigration
est définitivement adopté mais à quel
prix la majorité s'est fracturé sur les
251 députés du camp présidentiel 32 se
sont abstenus 27 ont voté contre le
texte c'est la fin de ce numéro des
grands débats à très vite sur
LCP
[Musique]